I'm really sorry I didn't think it would
end up like this I am a good person
that is who I am you better run
for your life
you're irredeemable so I wanted to start
with your work as director on the show
because of course you've directed
episodes in past Seasons but this marks
the the first time that you direct the
full season yourself so it was making me
wonder what is it about the season four
storyline that made you feel that it was
necessary to be at the at the helm for
every single episode it wasn't so much
the storyline it was more just that I
think when we bring in other directors
even when it's you know Alec Berg the
co-creator I just I just become more and
more confident as a director and and I
was driving people crazy because I was
like no no it's got to be over here I'm
like I saw it super specifically and I
think Aida Rogers our great producer at
the end of season three said you know I
think maybe you should direct them all
next season because I think it'll just
production will go smoother because it's
a big game of telephone you know so
um I I yeah sure and it was it was
overwhelming at times but it was
ultimately really rewarding oh for what
it's worth that confidence is not
misplaced you pull off some pretty
exceptional stuff this season it just
gets bigger and bigger thank you thank
you all right so I wanted to ask you a
little bit about bringing the series to
a close now specifically what your last
day on set was like are there any
specific memories that might stick with
you and maybe be a defining factor in
terms of how you'll look back on the
Barry experience overall no I mean I
just I mean bringing the show to a close
or bringing the you know the show and
the story to a close is really be
satisfying you know you want to finally
put the end on a thing is nice but the
harder thing is just saying goodbye to
the crew and the the cast who are just
these amazing artists that I've had the
privilege to work with uh for the last
six years and it's it's just been a
wonderful wonderful experience I mean
the best you know experience of my
career so that that's been the hardest
part is saying goodbye to everybody
so that just means you have to come up
with another idea yeah
no big deal at all
you have to ask about one specific scene
because Guillermo del Toro is one of my
favorite human beings in this industry
and pretty much on this planet so what
was it like directing a directing Legend
and what was it about him as an actor
that maybe caught you by surprise when
you worked with him yeah he was just
like hey I love your show and I'd love
to be on it and I said okay so wrote
them apart and then he I think was so
surprised that we actually did it
and then he came in and he was great you
know he was just super game he knew his
lines and had you know two different
takes on the scene and did them both and
and uh he was great and he was a
wonderful guy
does not surprised me to hear that one
bit uh given bringing him up right now I
am curious because the the tone of
season four feels a little different and
again you get very ambitious with some
of your directing choices in this
particular season so were there any new
influences directing influence Past film
past shows that you found yourself
referring to on season four that you had
never used before Carl Hersey the DP and
I would talk about you know different
movies or photography or certain things
you know
um an example I usually show people is
the opening of ashes and diamonds by
anje Vita that opening of that movie is
kind of like you know I really love how
this is shot and how it looks and how it
feels and then you you go through those
things of kind of those influences and
certain influences and um literature but
you know people like Tobias wolf or um
George Saunders or you know things like
that and then and then you put it
together and then you do it and then you
look at it and you're like oh I like the
Coen brothers
which I do but it's just yeah you can't
escape your I like Chrome Brothers
Scorsese Alfonso coron you know the the
all those people and it's awesome and
I'm like oh brother I can't it doesn't
matter how highfalutin I try to get with
the influence question it's like ah yeah
I didn't see it leading there with how
you teed it up but I get it yeah clearly
is Watch No Country for a man 100 times
and it's yeah the guy I was dating and I
like killed my acting teacher's
girlfriend
I think I might be in a lot of trouble
I got a big question for you to start
here so Sally's obviously gone through
quite a bit since the beginning of the
series of everything you filmed over the
course of the show's run is there a
particular scene that redefined the
character for you most where you know
you could feel everything you shot after
that moment basically influencing every
new scene you filmed I think there's a
few
like you know incremental moments like
that throughout but the big one would
have to be when she kills the biker
because it's just the point of no return
and suddenly she's accidentally
complicit in a whole other world that
she didn't even know she was
so close to
um and I think that you know Sally is
kind of morally dubious like all the
characters on the show but she knows not
to kill people she hasn't done that so
she's walked into a kind of dark space
that we haven't seen her in before and I
think it affects the entire season four
because she can't she can't wash that
memory off
can confirm that is true and I might
even call that an understatement
very
much so
I know you've mentioned before that the
the Sally and Barry relationship is is
basically one that's based on
projections being functional only
because they don't really see who each
other are so can you maybe tease how
that changes for Sally now that she has
heard about Barry's arrest and also what
he's actually done well I think it's
interesting because yeah I think over
the course of the last three seasons
that was the case their romance was
built on projections and then at the end
of three Sally is fully witnessed in her
most Base Animal rage mode by this man
so she's never been so seen and she sees
him clearly and the sad part is the the
one deep moment of connection they have
is in those moments after she's killed
him when they're when he's holding her
face and trying to take responsibility
so it was it was sort of like their
relationship was sort of now forged in
fire in this particular way and they're
Bound by this crime and and Bound by
Blood literally so when we get into
season four and she finds out what
Barry's done to Janice I think there's a
huge pivot where she's repelled and
shocked and angry and she can't believe
like that he's been lying to her all
this time and that he's maybe a
sociopath but she quite quickly realizes
how alone she is in the world with this
horrible thing that she's done and the
one person who was not only there to
Bear witness but also stood by her side
and loved her anyway is Barry so
strangely after not seeing each other
clearly for all these years
they do see each other and it's a really
ugly thing that they see
um and I think when she says I feel safe
with you it's that she's choosing to be
in proximity of someone who saw the
worst of her and stuck around oh that
line that line hits so so well
your last two answers are making me
think a little bit about this but it's
more of a theory question have you ever
considered what Sally's path might have
been if Barry had still gotten arrested
and exposed but she had never killed the
biker yeah I mean I think that there
would have been maybe some hope for her
that you know she well she sabotaged her
well her career fell apart and then she
self-sabotaged but I think that I think
that without that horrible thing that
happened her life had potential I mean
there's a lot of things she could have
done but once she's crossed that line I
think there's no going back sadly my
heart all right let's switch gears to
behind the scenes stuff now and of
course I wanted to follow up on working
with Bill as a director because of
course he directed a good deal on past
Seasons but this is different because he
directed the entire season so I was
wondering how did that change your
experience on set and maybe even how did
it influence your performance in a way
that felt necessary and helpful given
what Sally is going through in this
season versus the past three well I
think when we all found out he was going
to do all eight we were like wow are you
crazy
that is so much work
um but he was he had something in his
mind and he really saw his vision
through through and while maintaining a
you know collaborative atmosphere with
all of us I think that there were you
know he's really into film and
um has a pretty encyclopedic knowledge
of Cinema and he wanted to I think he
wanted to push the visual aesthetic of
the show this season and he got very
ambitious with the the way it was shot
and you know huge wides and lots of
Runners and I think that it gave the
show a new visual language that really
helps with where the story goes because
it's in such a new and
Bleak place with a few jokes there's
still a few laughs
um and so I think it was yeah it gave
the show like a very clear vision and we
all really signed up and took that
Collective jump together and I you know
got a credit HBO for really giving us
time like TV can move so fast and that's
that's really your enemy is that speed
but we were given so much time so we
could rehearse we could rehearse before
we were shooting there was so much time
for Creative conversations from
everything from hair and makeup to
costume to to shot setups to everything
so we were very well prepared so that on
the day if he's you know pivoting
between acting and directing it was
pretty seamless
Boudreau with him as well who's a good
old best pal of his um who was who was
able to help sort of direct his
performance and Aida Rogers our producer
is like I think she's a magical wizard I
don't know how she makes it all happen
it's like build dreams up or Alex dreams
up like these insane things and Aida
goes yep got it it doesn't even Flinch
and well there's no I can't give
spoilers but there's certain things we
shot this season that should have been
impossible and
um and I eat it really made them happen
so you need that you need that person
who can facilitate that kind of wild
vision and and Aida is the one makes my
day to hear about a supportive
environment on a set like that I
absolutely love it okay yeah we're
looking um can you tell me a little bit
about what your last day on set was like
and if there are any memories that'll
really stick with you and maybe wind up
being a defining factor in terms of how
you look back on your Barry experience I
mean it was totally surreal my last day
on set there was snow and so the whole
set just had this dreamlike quality and
it was like kind of walking into a snow
globe and yeah you know emotions we're
running high but you can't really yield
to that if it doesn't match the scene
you're shooting so like any other day
one foot in front of the other gotta say
the lines go to do your job and then
finally was my last take and no I did it
and then I asked bill if you need
another one and he said no I think we
got it and I said okay I guess we got it
and resisting the urge to be like let's
do it again and again and again like
don't let it end and so yeah that was it
and then you know the crew were gorgeous
and plotted and made a little speech to
them it was very sad saying goodbye to
the crew we have like the most
incredible crew in the world and I'm
sure we may work together again but not
in that Ensemble you know so
that I think that the the hard part was
just saying goodbye to the people but
there was satisfaction in in finishing
the story there was joy to that and and
yeah it really kind of everybody felt I
think everybody felt like their story
ended in a way that felt right what
happened back there I was just trying to
protect you I don't know what people are
telling you but I meant what I said to
you I love you Hey Barry I gotcha
I wanted to start by looking back a
little for you both because you two have
just this absolutely magnificent
confrontation in the season three finale
where Jim interrogates Gene so I was
wondering for both of you can you tell
me something about the other that you
appreciated as a scene partner that
really came in handy with doing a super
tense scene like that I will tell you
that I would not have been able to
accomplish that scene without my acting
partner uh we were in a room by
ourselves there was no crew they were on
the other side of the wall of the garage
there was only this big Metal Crane
two metal chairs gym and me and
I I was able to accomplish that scene
because of my acting partner yeah I I I
I can Echo that and what I
what really kind of woke up to me the
Brilliance of of Henry's creation Jean
Cousino
he was this narcissistic character who
sincerely wooed my daughter
and and fell in love with her it was a
real love because she felt it and I knew
that she felt it and then so this man
that I was confronting in the garage
had many layers that
came out in the midst of
our Exchange
at the top there was a deflection of a
narcissist what are you talking about as
we went into and then the then the
momentum just went to another place a
dark place where I was speaking from the
pain of losing my daughter and I spoke
to The Man Who Lost His Lady and
and I wanted the truth and I would have
if I could have gotten physical I would
have picked him up and pushed him
against the wall but we did it all with
just
it was the most real moment possible
Henry was intensely frightened and I was
intensely
Revenge
and um and it came out and no neither
one of us expected the Sparks to fly
like that and that's what uh this show
is really lucky at getting is just
really really real moments
yeah that's for sure the Sparks Fly big
there and elsewhere throughout season
four Henry I'll throw this one your way
because Four Seasons now the show is uh
is coming to a close with this one so
can you tell me a little bit about your
very last day on set and if there are
any memories that'll stick out to you
and you know maybe be a defining Factor
when you look back on your Barry
experience the last day of shooting
I am in the last shot by myself
I come out of a room and the crew is
there
and Bill hugs me and Whispers in my ear
thank you for being such a great
collaborator
he was my writer my producer my with
Alec Berg
my director and my acting partner
and for him to say that to me
was so emotional I can't tell you
everything okay
yeah
everything's gonna be great I want to
start with the uh Hank and crystal ball
relationship can you tell me if there's
a new layer that you got to tap into
when playing Hank because of that
connection to Crystal Ball something
that you know you never would have
explored with that character had they
not pursued their connection together oh
for sure I mean I think that the uh Hank
uh crystal ball kind of um
this this chemistry between them this
this dynamic between them has like
evolved I think so beautifully into into
something very like very heightened but
also really just kind of everyday I feel
like there's so many people who like
relate you know just just who they are
with each other I mean classic you know
who can't relate to to uh mob bosses
just in love with each other right we
can all and we can all take a page
um but I think yeah on a personal level
what I got to play in this this uh final
season with Michael Irby was just so
special and I'm so excited for audiences
to see just what we what we drum up and
uh and all the really kind of amazing
moments that play out between us can
confirm there's quite a few of them that
I might get to later but first i'm gonna
kind of turn that same question towards
Barry as well complicated two-parter
here but what is a particular quality or
strength that Hank gained from having
worked with and grown close to uh Barry
but then also I want the opposite a
weakness that hang only acquired due to
Barry's influence on him oh wow that's a
great question I'll start with the
weakness actually I mean I think this
season is kind of
um really about how how Barry's kind of
toxicity has rubbed off on each of these
characters right each of these
characters have kind of acquired Barry's
like sickness and and what's you know
what's going on with him and I think
Hank is is certainly is certainly one of
them
um I think that he is
kind of
wanting to be this thing that that
ultimately he is not and and it gets me
to a lot of trouble uh because of it
um now a positive thing that he's gained
from from Barry is um yeah probably I
think in a roundabout way I think Hank
learned how to say no and learn how to
really stand up for himself you know I
think at the beginning he was a people
pleaser and then it kind of morphed into
more of uh Hank uh saying no you know
Hank uh drawing a boundary it's a big
deal I'm curious if the answer to this
question is something very specific now
but obviously Hank's been through quite
a lot over the course of the show and
he's changed quite a bit of everything
you filmed for the entire series is
there any particular scene that you feel
redefined the character the most for you
something where after you shot that
particular scene you could feel that
material influencing everything you shot
after for Hank you know I think that
there was I mean there have been a lot
of moments that I feel like have just
found where I've found different layers
to this character uh and that's been so
special I mean there was a there was a
moment
um in season two where Hank fronts Barry
outside of the acting class and I feel
like that's a moment where you see Hank
be really uh scary you know but what I
like about it is is you know he's scary
not because he's this really menacing
mob boss but because his feelings were
hurt right he was like told he was an
idiot and that really hurt his feelings
and that was what propelled him to show
up and threaten Barry and he is
threatening but it's all coming from
that you know from that wounded place so
it's really yeah that's really cool it's
very smart let's feel like a lot of his
scary decisions come from you know that
kind of sensitive like genuine emotion
and I feel like that's why the character
resonates with so many right yeah maybe
sensitive people should not be mob
bosses maybe that's maybe that's you
know moral story you know oh I guess
that's one career path I am not pursuing
uh a specific scene uh in the new season
that I have to ask you about because
Guillermo del Toro is one of my absolute
favorite people in this industry just a
true ray of light what is it like acting
opposite a directing Legend and then
also maybe what surprised you about him
as an acting scene partner on set for
sure well I I had to really uh adjust my
nerves because I'm again I'm like like
like you such a huge fan of him and I
had to stop myself from picking his
brain about every single one of his
films that I just completely adore and
and instead just really focus on on what
we were doing but he made it very easy
because he was just so Charming he has
such a big heart and and uh and such a
lovely attitude uh it's fun too because
specifically when we were working
together you know there was a moment
where we were trying to figure out a
part of the scene and I saw his kind of
director hat go on and and it was
fascinating because then I saw him kind
of move into this place of of curiosity
and whatever it is that makes his films
just so gorgeous and so realized I was
like that's it right there oh my God I'm
witnessing it wow very lucky now I'm
curious if you weren't holding back what
one gear mode Toro directed film would
you have done anything to ask him about
oh my God Pan's Labyrinth yeah I was
like I I but but you know I was like one
day we're gonna be best friends so you
know one day I'll bring it up to him
dude's got a big heart I wouldn't be
surprised if you stayed close friends
yeah um so obviously I have to ask you
about Barry coming to a close and
specifically I want to know what was
your very last day on set like and were
there any memories that you think will
stick with you and maybe wind up being a
defining factor in how you look back on
your experience making the show yeah the
final day was um it was one that was you
know really sad and really beautiful I
mean I but I did really make a point to
just take everything in you know I would
stop and just take a moment to to be
present with exactly where I was and
take stock of the entire Journey that
has been leading up to that moment and
um and yeah and I think the every every
time I got to go to work was just a
defining moment I I think I grew as an
actor and as an artist and as a person
because of the show so um yeah and I'm
excited for people to to see it all
realized in this in this fourth season I
would definitely believe everything you
just said and given the fact that I keep
hearing everybody having wonderful
experiences working on bill with the
show overall is there anything about him
as like not just a co-star but also a
director and a leader on this set that
you really appreciated and hope to have
on your onset environments and other
shows and films in the future I'm
honestly so spoiled we are so spoiled to
have someone like Bill because he he's
so fast and so efficient and so
brilliant all at once and so you know we
have like half days basically I mean
there's been so many scenes that we just
you know because of his preparation
because he has it all together and
because he knows what he wants uh things
move really quickly and and
um but he's also really curious and lets
you do whatever you want so again oiled
um but I I don't have you know there
there's so much good that I can say
about Bill Hader he's just a genius and
I want to work with him again oh yeah I
don't I don't blame you given everything
I've heard he definitely said like
similar to Guillermo sounds like a very
positive force with a big heart in this
industry we need more of those I've
saved my favorite question for last
right now I need to know what do you
think Hank's favorite game to play or
thing to do in Dave and Buster's is
oh wow oh my God what a great question
now we're getting to it okay
um let's see I would think
um yeah like definitely air hockey okay
you know step to this and you're going
to lose all right because that disc is
going to be flying towards your face and
it's gonna take you out all right
um yeah let's do it air hockey 100 Eric
betrayed me I showed him how I really
felt and he betrayed me
been through quite a bit since the very
beginning of the series absolutely of
everything you filmed for this show is
there any particular scene that you
found redefined the character the most
for you something where everything you
filmed after that moment wound up being
heavily influenced by that particular
scene oh that's a good question
um
probably
uh we were talking earlier today about
uh the Ronnie Lilly episode
um where the girl uh bites me on the
cheek and then and then right after that
she runs away and blood streaming down
her her face and I say what are you and
I think that's the defining moment of
fuges from then on it's like what is
happening yeah I think that is uh that's
a very very fair one to bring up to
focus on season four in particular now
even after three seasons of really big
moments for him like that when you first
read the season four scripts was there
any particular scene or thing he goes
through that made you think like wow I
never could have imagined I'd get the
opportunity to go there with this
character yeah well that happened later
in the show for sure because you'll see
yes you see the characters that you
thought you knew are going to be
different by the end of this season so
yeah I didn't uh we we don't like you
guys we don't get you know all all eight
scripts in a bunch we get them piecemeal
uh at the same time but I personally I
love to focus on what my character is
doing the through line of what's just
happened before what could happen
uh later but I don't want I don't even
want to read more than once the script
for what other people have is because
I'm a fan I want to see I just I don't
want to know what happens to them I want
to see it on the screen so I I
specifically try not to read a script
very carefully except for what I have to
do to do my work correctly so four full
seasons of this show now it is coming to
a close can you tell me a little bit
about what your very last day on set was
like and if there were any moments from
that day that you think might stick with
you and be defining factors and how you
look back on your Barry experience I
have to say truthfully I wasn't sad that
the show was ending because I think the
Arc of a character with PTSD has to in
reality just it's gonna go down it's not
going to go up so I wasn't unhappy that
the reality of the show was ending I was
unhappy about not being able to see
people you know that you've become
become a family with you're on set you
see those people more than your family
so they become your family for that time
same with I did 13 years on King of the
Hill I saw marriage divorce babies you
know Birds
uh and this is like that but uh I think
that since this cast is a little smaller
than that one uh we are very bonded and
I I don't see us letting go like you
know when you come in and do a couple of
shows for somebody else you don't
necessarily connect with them all of us
are connected and love each other and I
think we'll stay that way I keep hearing
that it sounds like a top-down effect
like Bill Bill set the right tone on set
and really encourage that kind of
collaboration
Bill and Alec uh as Henry will tell you
had an election policy and and that's
true the on down to the smallest crew
member to the craft Services everybody
was
there to do their best every single set
should operate with that policy in mind
I agree with you 110 percent all right
sticking with Bill now I'm curious about
his approach to working on Barry as not
just the star of the show but also a
director and an overall leader on this
set and I got a two-parter for you on
that what's something about his approach
to being a leader on Barry that has
stayed the same since day one of making
the show but then also what is something
new he did on season four that signaled
to you that he's honed his craft
significantly over the years yeah well
first of all the fact that he directed
all eight episodes of season four gives
you uh confidence that uh his producers
and his fellow Creator have that much
confidence in that Singularity of vision
for this whole season that should give
him confidence that people like what
he's doing I thought he directed The the
pilot of this show I thought he did a
pretty good job as a first-time director
but having then directed maybe three the
next season and then five and then so uh
I have only
unlimited respect for his his
directorial abilities but the fact that
he's able to juggle them you know and
wear that many hats and he's dressed at
his his prison outfit telling me what to
do in a prison
um as a producer as a director as a
fellow actor and
um as a writer and because we we all
write a little bit on set and smudge
things around but this man is wearing
all hats at the same time and I I
have enormous respect for that